welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
aka the guy with a bobber fetish that
felt a bit let down by the lack of the
macho mandalorian in this episode
after last week's cliffhanger it did
seem like he was going to be a big part
of this entry
but unfortunately it looks like we're
going to have to wait longer than the
sarlacc's digestion period
to see him again sad times anyway
there's still
a lot to unpack and this episode centers
around mando
basically doing an escort mission
through hogwarts forbidden forest
with mo's pickled eggs it feels very
fillery
and in the grand scheme of things i
don't think much happens
however break it down we must now we
pick up immediately after last week's
entry with mando racing across tatooine
on his speeder
we didn't mention it last week but i
believe that this is actually anakin
speeder from attack of the clones
and if our theories about cobb vance
being his pod racer are true
then this is a nice little nod to both
the rides that the character had on the
planet
some raiders in the desert set up a trap
for the character in order to try and
capture the child
however mando uses his wits to defeat
them and after tricking one of them into
taking his jet pack
he sends the character flying through
the air now when they used
rope to bring down the speeder i was a
little bit worried about baby oda
however seeing seeing what the guy does
in this episode
i'm actually i'm actually pretty mad at
him i'm i'm just kidding i can't stay
mad at you
now after the title scene we cut to
mando arriving at mos
eisley namely the cantina you may
remember that when it first appeared in
a new hope
there was a strict no droids policy
however
last season we saw that this had been
lifted as
one was serving behind the bar and it
looks like it's retained its job
as it still remains here pelimoto is
playing sabac with an insectoid who she
refers to as dr mandible
and this famous card game has appeared
at multiple points throughout the saga
han solo actually won the millennium
falcon from lando calrissian whilst
playing this game
after the former stole one of the
latter's cards which stopped him from
cheating
from ant-man mandel learns of a contact
that will apparently take him to some
mandalorians
and he returns to the hangar from last
week with pelly to meet our female frog
contact
who pretty much becomes central to the
episode now i'm not
100 on this species here but i believe
it's the female version of one of the
lizard-like aliens that we saw in the
cantina during a new hope
she sort of becomes the mcguffin of the
episode and this children of men
ask entry sees mando escorting her and
her
eggs across the galaxy she wants to
reach the estuary moon of trask
which will be hospitable for her
children here with her husband
their species will rise again and this
must be completed before the equinox
in order to stop her line from ending
now an equinox is actually the instant
of time when the plane of our earth's
equator passes through the geometric
center of the sun's disk
this occurs twice a year around the 20th
of march and 23rd of september
but who knows how it differs in the star
wars galaxy
now she has apparently seen mandalorians
on the planet
but whether this will turn out to be
related to sabine wren or not
remains to be seen i kind of wish this
was a longer entry and
we got more substantial plot development
here as
like i've said i don't really feel like
it advanced the story that much
it did however make me want to have some
medium rare dragon steak
and eggs now i love how they basically
have a droid
cooking the crate dragon stake in front
of a pod racer engine
i think that it may actually be
subulba's however it is difficult to
make out
mano is unable to jump to hyperspace
because of the eggs
and thus he must carefully navigate to
the system avoiding a giant nest of
spiders
and baby odor who who also seems
determined to end the species
to make matters worse when the group
entered the sector they're swarmed by a
pair of x-wings that are patrolling the
area
looking for imperial holdouts we learned
that all craft must run beacons since
the fall of the empire
and you really get the idea that the
rebels may be as controlling as the
imperials were
however they simply don't really have
the manpower to run the galaxy properly
there were several theories that they
relied too heavily on droids
which we saw as part of the prisoner
episode last season
and this pretty much caused a lot of
instability across the galaxy
thus the first order was able to rise
and this aesthetic kind of teases
towards the events of the force awakens
now through subtitles i'll learn that
the names of these pilots were carson
and wolfe
unfortunately this isn't commander wolfe
who you may know from clone wars
but the white beard could be a little
nod towards him
they try and verify who mando is but due
to him being on the run
because of the events of chapter 6 he
refuses to hand over his pin
and tries to outrun them this leads to a
chase through the skies and the group
crash on an ice planet
which leaves them stranded there for
pretty much the rest of the episode
now when this first appeared in the
trailers for the show many believed that
it was ilium
however if the theories about her
becoming starkiller base are true
then that would mean that construction
would be well underway at this point
and thus it probably isn't the ship gets
busted up badly
and with baby yoda eating eggs like
they're going out of fashion
they're on a pretty tight clock due to
the language barrier
mando and the frog female are unable to
communicate with one another
however they managed to talk after she
activates zero
who too appeared in the prisoner episode
that entry becomes integral to this one
and after mando saved lieutenant devan
he pretty much receives a get out of
jail free card
which we'll get into in just a bit now
the actor who played divan
has also played anakin skywalker several
times so it's nice that they brought him
up again here
anyway zero voiced by richard iote helps
the female to talk
and she pretty much guilt-trips mando
into honoring his word
she ends up leaving the craft in order
to take a hot bath with her eggs
and mano follows her using the detective
vision that he also put in place to
follow cara dune
upon arriving at the hot baths all hell
breaks loose
as baby oda unwittingly awakens a swarm
of spiders
what the hell is the matter with you
have you have you not been watching
alien you idiot
now we don't know what this species is
for definite
but i think that it's a cricketer
typically these creatures are natives of
atollin
however that planet doesn't really look
like the one we see in this entry
so i'm not sure that they're the same
quickness are actually resistant to
blaster bolts
and this invulnerability ranges from
rifles all the way up to ship blasters
that isn't really the case here which is
why i have some doubts
however they are very similar in design
due to their sensitivity to their
environment
they're actually very difficult to
control or tame with the force
and even the most accomplished jedi have
difficulty combating them
after capturing their prey they tend to
cocoon them in their underground hives
and using their fangs they feast on
whoever is unlucky enough to get caught
in their web
their weakness is primarily the signals
emitted by sensor beacons
and damaging their eyes also paints them
to great effect
the creatures have also appeared on
dagobah and
they're pretty much an arachnophobic's
worst nightmare now whilst mando and co
managed to escape their lair
the race is sworn by the creatures it's
only upon the arrival of carson and wolf
that the group has saved
and we discover that they've decided to
let mano go because of the good deeds
that he did during the prisoner episode
his mission of course led to the capture
of several highly wanted criminals
as well as the death of ran who we know
was running the organization
thus they chalk this up as even and
allow mano to get away scot-free
i also love how we can see little tie
fighter symbols on their craft
which showcases how many ships they've
taken down
mando fixes up the crest and together
with the group he continues his journey
to trask
and hopefully more mandalorians we learn
that they won't be able to leave the
cockpit as that's the only place mando
can pressurize
and it's safe to say that the ship has
seen better days now going forward
i do think that we will be seeing sabine
wren sooner rather than later
the episode she appears in seems like
it's taking place on a ferry
and if mano is still escorting the
female and her eggs
then he'll likely have to go across this
the razor he busts up at this point
so i can imagine that he'll have to
arrange alternate transport
in order to get her to a goal there's
also the fact that boba fett is out
there in the galaxy
aware that mando has his armor i can't
really see him returning
until i go back to tatooine however with
the armor being taken off planet
he could indeed be heading out after
them i really did hope that we would
just jump straight into that story
so it was a bit frustrating to not have
that tease last time really go anywhere
but then i don't know what i'm talking
about because mandalorian has always
been like that anyway
as i said this episode was a bit fillery
and hopefully next time we're in for
a bit more plot progression than what we
got here obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the episode so make sure you
comment below and let me know
if you enjoyed this video then please
drop a thumbs up make sure you check out
our breakdown of cobb vance which is
going to be linked at the end
we go over everything you need to know
about the character and his role in the
expanded universe so it's definitely
worth checking out if you want to know
more
don't forget we're giving away three
copies of the marvel phase 2 box set
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of november so make sure you
get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat just on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter
thanks for making it until the end of
the video you've been the best i've been
paul i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you